[Musique]
des hôpitaux plein à craquer des salles
d'attente bondées un système de santé en
crise pour y faire face l'Ontario prend
la voix de la privatisation
à marteler donc Ford
créativité qui se traduirait surtout par
l'élargissement du rôle des cliniques
privées la province injectera quelques
20 millions de dollars pour y financer
certaines opérations et aux Ontariens
préoccupés par la privatisation dogford
fait cette promesse
ils n'auront jamais à utiliser leurs
cartes de crédit chez le médecin
mais les promesses du Premier ministre
sont loin de rassurer l'opposition
officielle qui crée les dérapages
beaucoup de professionnels de la santé
s'inquiètent aussi d'une cannibalisation
des ressources on n'est pas capable de
venir à bout d'avoir le personnel dans
le secteur à des hôpitaux pourquoi
est-ce que ce serait mieux de faire un
système parallèle
devant cette levée de bouclier le
gouvernement fédéral se fait discret
juste un Trudeau en plein négociation
avec les provinces sur la question des
transferts de santé n'a pas critiqué la
décision du gouvernement Ford on va
toujours veiller à ce que la loi
canadienne soit santé soit respectée en
même temps on sait à quel point c'est
important de livrer à l'intérieur des
conditions de la Loi canadienne sur la
santé les améliorations dans les
systèmes de santé à travers le pays donc
faut être premier que le mois de mars
son plan permettra de réduire les temps
d'attente pour les chirurgies au niveau
prépondémique le gouvernement ontarien
fait le pari qu'avec des résultats
rapides pour les patients la pilule de
la privatisation sera plus facile à
avaler ici Radio-Canada Toronto